foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
happy Tuesday everyone now we have first
order of business did you buy cat's book
yet
[Applause]
that's more than a smattering
and not just for the pictures if it's
not number one she said she'll shive me
in the kidney and she means the good one
I wonder can you live with zero kidneys
I know for a fact you can live for years
without a brain
be successful
now that that's out of the way a new
Gallup poll shows a record number of
Americans are identifying as politically
independent 49 in fact compared to 25
percent who identify as Republicans and
another 25 who identify as female
competitive swimmers
Independence accounted for the lowest
percentage of Voters as seen in this
easy to understand graph
yeah I drew that on the way home last
night Pete hegseth gives one hell of a
piggyback ride
so you might be asking yourself self
what happened since 2004 I mean other
than Joe Biden's hair plugs turning 60.
points to the disillusionment with the
political system U.S institutions and
the two parties which are seen as
ineffectual too political and too
extreme so yeah you could say people are
fed up with two parties but we've been
saying that forever something different
is going on first believing in the
Constitution a strong border low taxes
and basic biology is an extreme in fact
the only thing extreme about Republicans
is their love for balance of nature
[Applause]
yeah
just last night I couldn't walk into the
studio but then I took balance of nature
and I had two men Carry Me In
so could it be this current
Administration is so incompetent and far
left it scared the living data everybody
creating a new pool of liberals who
can't recognize liberals anymore think
about it who would have thought there
would be a party who Champions drag
queens as in-school entertainment
who would have thought there would be a
party that happily defends grown men
beating women in sports
who would have thought there would be a
party run by people who collectively
fart dust
means they're old
here's another theory I thought up while
in the shower popping Larry kudlow's
back acne
[Laughter]
every Everybody Has It people are going
independent because there's just no
accountability anymore bad stuff just
disappears much like Jesse Waters when
the bill comes
and the disappearances only go in One
Direction some Democrats commit crimes
and walk away scot-free meanwhile a
Trumper makes one mistake at the Capitol
in jail to this day that should
disillusion anyone there are other head
scratchers too like whatever happened to
Jeffrey Epstein's Client List seems like
it's the only classified dock under lock
and key these days my theory is Hillary
is resting on top of it her folds of
warm skin protecting it like a male
penguin does an egg
oh
yeah it was Visual and what's up with
the Trans Nashville Shooters Manifesto
hell if only we had that kind of
stonewalling for the southern border add
that to a list of things you will never
see you know right after killmey's next
book
foreign
did the government ever find out who
leaked the Supreme Court decision
overturning Roe v Wade that should be
easier to find than the leak Biden left
on the Oval Office rug
I say put the suspects in a room and
show outnumbered until someone confesses
in the meantime they sick the FBI on
Trump over his classified docks and
tracked down some nerdy National
Guardsmen for leaking secrets about our
involvement in Ukraine turns out our
government's been totally lying about
that war like they do about every war
but like I told that guy who sold me
meat out of his van
I'm not stupid
the pork shank was still wearing socks
meanwhile Hunter's laptop Joe Biden's
own carelessness with documents who
cares right it's funny these things seem
to break the Democrats way all the time
meanwhile Trump can't fart without being
investigated for it speaking of which
Eric swalwell still had sex with Chinese
spies and that stinks more than his
boxers
no wonder we're sick of politicians and
like Joe Biden's nurses were also sick
of their
perhaps it's this thumb on the scale
that makes us go independent the extreme
left wants to shove bugs down your
throat then wash it down with Bud Light
they want to ban your gas oven and have
privileged discussions with your kid
over gender my rule never trusted adult
who says to a child this will be our
little secrets I learned that from my
uncle
and his bowling team
point is it's natural for us to
gravitate to one party's ideas but
imagine you're just a moderate Dem they
do exist but then the party slips in
some crazy crap and people are like whoa
this wasn't part of the plan it's like
dropping a political roofie in your
drink the next thing you know you're
like why is math Mass theft legal what
happened to cash bail why is there a fat
hairy dude dressed as a lady squatting
in my living room teaching my
three-year-old to twerk
and how did Wolf Blitzer get the keys to
my house
[Laughter]
so cheers to The Independents but just
remember come election time maybe try
something new if you can't make up your
mind pick the person who does the least
amount of damage these days that's
almost always going to be a Republican
let's welcome tonight's guests in 2019
her mouth's at the North American land
speed record co-host of outnumbered
Emily campagno
he served the perps they're just
desserts former NYPD inspector Paul
Morrow
[Applause]
he travels the country curing and
causing sex addictions osab asked Dr
Drew Dr Drew Pinsky
and finally she's like a construction
site kinda loud and old men are always
stopping by to stare Fox News
contributor cat tip foreign
Emily what do you think changed people's
political affiliations what created all
these Independents you claimed to be a
lawyer do you have some insight into
this well just my opinion on this one
which I think two things have happened
number one I think the Democrat Party
has absolutely fallen off the rails to
your point it's like searching for a
needle in a haystack if we can find a
moderate them and I think frankly as
people appreciate common sense of oh my
streets are filthy my kids aren't safe
they're being indoctrinated I actually
do believe in simple biology just the
fundamentals of life liberty and the
protection of our borders that they
recognize that that party is no longer
anywhere near any of that and the second
thing is I think that the caustic
atmosphere that has been created and
furthered mostly by the woke left on
social media in mainstream media think
about the polls that have come out where
over half of respondents say they
wouldn't go on a date with someone of
the other political party six out of ten
students say they wouldn't room with
another student of the other political
party almost seven say they wouldn't
marry someone who voted for a different
party so in a way I think registering as
independent simply gets you into the
pool where you're like you know what I'm
safe I can be normal I'm not in one of
those tribal you know this side of the
bench or this side of the bench and then
it doesn't matter how I made my way
eventually to as they say I can vote for
normal and then I'll just conclude by
pointing out that the Republican party
is gaining however black Americans and
Hispanic Americans in record numbers are
joining the GOP so that shows you that
while the independent number is growing
yes so too is the GOP because they are
rational common sense and life liberty
and freedom very good
Paul you claim to be in law enforcement
um I do yes uh do you think people are
just too scared to say what they are
right now I do actually you know what I
mean I'm gonna push back on the entire
premise of this poll right because first
of all these are the same people who
always tell us how polarized the country
is right so if we're so completely
polarized how can we have this big
squishy 50 in the middle right so why
are they doing that you got to say it to
yourself now these polls are always
taken into urban areas you go up to
somebody in New York City with a
clipboard and you ask him so what's your
party affiliation yeah there were two
safe answers Democrat and communist yes
so if you say independent what that
really means is hyper hypermaga yeah and
that's it's a it's essentially a safe
answer because you don't feel like
getting into a fist fight that day so
you have to say to yourself why are they
putting it out now and I think it goes
what you were saying Greg what's really
going on is you're seeing the blue
collars shifting to the right because
they don't want Bud Light cans and all
that sort of stuff and then we all know
what's being shoved in our faces and
they're just going to to deal with it
and so this is essentially a way to
cover I think a significant shift in the
electorate we'll see but the fact that
Lee zeldin almost got the governorship
in New York and the last poll tells you
a lot yeah this is again why I have a
clipboard
you can go up to anybody and ask them a
question about something with your
clipboard yeah try that yeah that'll be
good yeah yes yes
you got to take Brian Selter off it
though
[Laughter]
be a doctor yeah I do as Paul would say
I do yeah are you these people are just
waiting waiting till the very are they
could it be that Independents are just
more normal people in the sense that
they don't pay attention like they're
into the playoffs right now
they're normal people I am unindependent
I have been for years I actually thought
I was a Libertarian until I met Captain
ah and I thought oh that's a Libertarian
I have a heart I can't do that now
no no it's not nice I have a heart I
care about all of the same issues
everyone does I just happen to think the
government's not the answer to solving
them yeah yeah it looked it was hard for
me to to be harsh that way whatever it
is I I thought I want government to
solve certain things but you know in
California you can register you can
re-register every 10 minutes yeah so
I've been in both parties but years ago
I finally went independent and have been
so ever since because the extremes on
both sides are problematic did you take
the hormones
when I was transitioning yeah when
you're transitioning um I I sort of went
hyper male instead of switching up
exactly oh that's right you were going
you weren't going to the Democratic
party that's when they have though they
have the whole they have the puberty
blockers can I take girl hormones not
now but to get my boobs big
um doctor
sometimes it helps sometimes it doesn't
so I'm not so wait we'll talk later yeah
yeah no doubt do you know that here's
the deal I know what you're going to say
cat you're going to say but wait Greg
you're not talking about the libertarian
uh alternative there is a third party
out there my theory and I said this to
you once before is to have a third party
that's capable you also need a fourth
party because the third party always
hurts the other party it's closest to so
you need to have a competing fourth
party so then you have a better chance
the third party and the fourth party has
a better chance of winning without
actually harming the other two parties
that are there more most like which is
what happened with Ross Perot uh causing
uh Clinton I think Clinton to win and
whenever you vote for a third party
whoever loses blames you yes but beside
that wins is never like thank you yeah
so I know that no matter what happens
when I vote libertarian my person's
gonna lose and half the country's going
to hate me
uh if I had that much power my person
might win sometimes yeah but I actually
I think that everybody or a lot of
conservatives seems to understand Market
forces and competition but they don't
see how that would be better if there
was way more candidates and there would
be a competition there'd be better
candidates because I think with the
two-party system that's how a lot of
corruption is allowed to happen because
they just play us against each other
which is a sort of distraction while
they're able to get away with all kinds
of Nefarious behavior and by the way and
take our money and take our rights away
and we just sit there yeah well they're
not taking away the rights as bad as
these people are and we're arguing about
that while we're being totally taken
advantage of so that's why I'm an
independent and that's why I vote third
party all right well we've got to go
before we go you can clap I'll talk
we'll do it together tickets are
available for my next book tour I'll be
hitting up Atlanta cities in Florida
they exist there Emily Rhode Island
Pennsylvania and I'll have a special
guest whose name is Tom shallou go to
gutfeld.com for tickets before it's too
late
[Applause]
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else